THAT AND MORE IN SEEN AND
UNSEEN, BUT FIRST, EDDIE NANCY
AND PRIGGISH MITT.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
DONALD TRUMP JUST CAPPED OFF A
PHENOMENAL WEEK FOR THE
PRESIDENCY AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THE SIGNING OF THE USMCA,
REMARKABLE PRIVATE SECTOR JOBS
NUMBERS, STOCK MARKET THAT HAS
SHAKEN OFF EVEN THE CORONAVIRUS
AND THE CHERRY ON TOP, AS SEAN
JUST MENTIONED, HIS ACQUITTAL ON
BOTH ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT
EARLIER TODAY.
IT’S LARGELY BECAUSE OF THESE
CONTINUED SUCCESSES THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS EXPOSED THE
FRAUDS ON THE LEFT.
THEY JUST CAN’T TAKE IT ANYMORE.
AND ONE IN PARTICULAR ON THE
RIGHT.
LET’S START WITH NANCY PELOSI.
LAST NIGHT SHE SHOWED THE WORLD
WHO SHE REALLY IS, A WOMAN LEFT
WITH LITTLE ELSE BUT HER OWN
SOUR POST-FACIAL EXPRESSION AND
A PAPER RIPPING STUNT.
SHE LET HER ANGER GET THE BEST
OF HER AND HER WHITE SUIT DIDN’T
MAKE HER LOOK ANYMORE ANGELIC.
IT WAS THE COLOR OF SURRENDER.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: SHE WASN’T THE ONLY
PERSON ACTING OUT.
UTAH JUNIOR SENATOR REMINDED US
OF WHY HE COULDN’T CONNECT WITH
MOST REGULAR WORKING CLASS
PEOPLE.
THEY DON’T LIKE POLITICIANS WHO
CLAIM TO BE HOLIER-THAN-THOU
WHEN THEY ARE REALLY JUST
STICKING A SHAVE IN YOUR BACK.
>> MY PREMISE BEFORE GOD TO
APPLY IMPARTIAL JUSTICE REQUIRED
THAT I PUT MY PERSONAL FEELINGS
AND POLITICAL BIASES ASIDE.
WERE I TO IGNORE THE EVIDENCE
THAT HAS BEEN PRESENTED, IT
WOULD, I FEAR, EXPOSE MY
CHARACTER TO HISTORY’S REBUKE.
>> Laura: IT HAS EXPOSED IT
ALL RIGHT.
HE IS THE ULTIMATE SELFISH,
PREENING, SELF-CENTERED
POLITICIAN.
AND HE HAS GOOD HAIR.
AND A SORT OF OKAY SINGING VOICE
VOICE.
♪ AMERICA, AMERICA ♪
♪ GOD SHED HIS GRACE ON THE ♪
>> Laura: IT DIDN’T WORK.
HE SHOULD TRY OUT FOR "THE
MASKED SINGER" WHEN HE LOSES
REELECTION.
HE WANTED DESPERATELY TO BE
TRUMP’S SECRETARY OF STATE AND
THEN HE CAST THIS FUTILE,
POINTLESS VOTE TO CONVICT HIM IN
ORDER TO SHOW THAT HE IS A MAN
OF PRINCIPLE, UNLIKE ALL THESE
OTHER REPUBLICANS.
IT’S CALLED PAYBACK.
BUT IF HE WERE UP FOR REELECTION
THIS YEAR, THE PEOPLE OF UTAH
WOULD HAVE THEIR OWN PAYBACK
AGAINST HIM.
BECAUSE THEY WERE DEFRAUDED BY
ROMNEY, FOR WHEN HE HAD TO
CHOOSE HE CHOSE CHUCK SCHUMER
AND KAMALA OVER COMMON SENSE AND
CONSERVATISM.
IF YOU ARE ONE OF ROMNEY’S
CONSTITUENTS IN UTAH, YOU ARE
OUT OF LUCK.
IF YOU ARE A BUSINESSMAN IN NEED
OF A REGULATION RE-EXAMINED,
DON’T BOTHER CALLING HIS OFFICE.
HE HAS NO POWER ANYMORE.
IF HE EVEN ATTENDS THE
REPUBLICAN CONVENTION AT ALL, HE
IS GOING TO GET BOOED.
MANY OF HIS COLLEAGUES WILL
FREEZE HIM OUT.
IF YOU WILL TRUST HIM AGAIN.
AND COULD YOU BLAME HIM?
AND LET’S NOT FORGET WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS AND MEDIA SAID ABOUT
HIM IN 2012.
>> INSULTING, A BINDER FULL OF
WOMEN.
THE BIGGER HIS IRISH SETTER IS
STRAPPED TO THE ROOF OF HIS CAR
DURING A ROAD TRIP.
>> HAVE YOU STRAP YOUR CAR TO
>> EXPANDING ONE OF HIS HOMES BY
ADDING A CAR ELEVATOR.
SPEAK OF THE ELITE AS HIM, THAT
IS WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
WHO CAN FEEL ANYTHING IN COMMON
WITH MITT ROMNEY?
>> Laura: BACK THEM THERE WERE
ONLY A FEW OF US ON TV AND
RADIO THAT DEFENDED YOU AND WE
DID THIS BECAUSE WE THOUGHT YOU
WOULD BE BETTER FOR AMERICA.
AND THE WAY YOU REPAY MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE, THE MILLIONS WHO DID
VOTE FOR YOU IN 2012 IS TO THROW
IN THE VERY PEOPLE WHO DON’T
SHARE OUR GOALS, WHO HATE US AND
BY THE WAY, STILL HATE YOU.
DOES HE NOT SEE WHAT ADAM SCHIFF
AND PETOSI AND FEINSTEIN HAVE
DONE TO CALIFORNIA?
AND DOES HE NOT KNOW THAT IF
THEY GOT REAL POWER, THEY WOULD
DO TO SALT LAKE CITY WHAT
THEY’VE DONE TO SAN FRANCISCO?
WILL HE HAVE THE COURAGE TO HAVE
A REAL TOWN HALL TO DEFEND THIS
BOAT?
HE COULDN’T EVEN GET SIMPLE
FACTS RIGHT WHILE DEBATING OBAMA
OBAMA.
>> IT WAS NOT A SPONTANEOUS
DEMONSTRATION.
IS THAT WHAT YOU WERE SAYING?
>> PLEASE PROCEED, GOVERNOR.
>> I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE GET
THAT FOR THE RECORD BECAUSE IT
TOOK THE PRESIDENT 14 DAYS
BEFORE HE CALLED THE ATTACK IN
BENGHAZI AN ACT OF TERROR.
>> GET THE TRANSCRIPT.
>> HE DID IN FACT, SIR.
>> CAN YOU SAY THAT A LITTLE
LOUDER?
>> HE DID CALL IT AN ACT OF
TERROR.
>> ROMNEY COULDN’T EVEN HAVE A
COMEBACK TO THE COORDINATED
RESPONSE WITH OBAMA.
THAT TOLD YOU ALL HE NEEDED TO
KNOW.
ALL OF THIS IS A GOOD REMINDER.
THAT KIND OF PYLON FOR THE SAKE
OF PILING ON HIM, BUT WE HAVE TO
LEARN FROM ALL OF THIS.
THIS ENTIRE IMPEACHMENT DEBACLE
WHAT A DISASTER THE G.O.P.
ESTABLISHMENT WAS FOR AMERICA.
THINK ABOUT IT.
MITT ROMNEY IS THE
ESTABLISHMENT.
THEY WERE WRONG ON CHINA, THEY
WERE WRONG ON A RACK, THEY WERE
WRONG ON IMMIGRATION, WRONG ON
THE HOUSING BUBBLE, WRONG ON
THE BAILOUT, WRONG ON THINGS
LIKE HARRIET MYERS AND DAVID
SOUTER.
FOR THE G.O.P. ESTABLISHMENT IT
WAS ALWAYS ABOUT WHAT WAS GOOD
FOR THEM PERSONALLY OR THEIR
CONSCIENCE OR WALL STREET, NOT
WHAT WAS GOOD FOR THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN.
FOR A FEW BRIEF, SHINING MOMENTS
IN 2008 AND 2012, SOME OF US
THOUGHT THAT ROMNEY HAD A SOLID
CORE.
BOY, DID HE FOOL US.
HE WAS A MASSACHUSETTS LIBERAL
IN 1994 WHEN HE RAN AGAINST TED
KENNEDY FOR THE SENATE.
THEN HE MOVED A BIT TO THE RIGHT
WHEN HE RAN FOR GOVERNOR.
THEN HE CLAIMED HE WAS A
FULL-BLOWN CONSERVATIVE WHEN HE
FIRST RAN FOR PRESIDENT IN 2008
AND NOW, LIKE ALL THE OTHER
BITTER NEVER-TRUMPERS, HE WOULD
RATHER SEE THE ENTIRE AMERICAN
ECONOMY GO DOWN THE DRAIN THEN
GIVE TRUMP A VICTORY.
>> FIRST, I DO WANT TO SALUTE
MITT ROMNEY.
>> THE VERDICT OF HISTORY IS
GOING TO BE ON MITT ROMNEY’S
SIGN.
>> HE SEEMS TO BE REACHING FOR
THE GHOST OF JOHN McCAIN.
>> HE CHANGED THE COURSE OF
HISTORY.
>> THAT WAS A REAL ACT OF
COURAGE.
>> MITT ROMNEY GIVES ME HOPE FOR
THE FUTURE.
>> Laura: MITT, YOU MADE YOUR
STAND, NOW YOU SHOULD RESIGN.
ARE YOU COMMITTED A FRAUD ON THE
PEOPLE OF UTAH ON THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, ON THE CONSTITUTION, AND
HAVE THOROUGHLY EMBARRASSED
YOURSELF.
CANTOR WAS BOUNCED OUT OF
OFFICE, THEY JUST WEREN’T IN
SYNC WITH THE PRIORITIES OF MOST
AMERICAN REPUBLICAN VOTERS AND
NEITHER ARE YOU.
UTAH DOES NOT NEED SOMEONE WHO
DOESN’T GET THEIR PHONE CALLS
RETURNED.
THEY NEED AN ACTUAL, FUNCTIONING
SENATOR AND MIKE LEE CAN’T DO
EVERYTHING.
FOLKS ARE SUPPOSED TO ENTER
POLITICS TO ADVANCE POLICIES
THAT IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
EVERYDAY AMERICANS.
THAT IS WHAT TRUMP DID AND HIS
POLICIES ARE WORKING.
BUT ROMNEY APPARENTLY WENT INTO
POLITICS BECAUSE OF HIS DAD OR
BECAUSE HE WANTED EVERYONE TO
THINK HE WAS A GOOD PERSON.
HE NEVER ACTUALLY WINS ARGUMENTS
OR PERSUADES ANYONE OF ANYTHING.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY, ONE
MAN WAS TRYING TO IMPRESS THE
ELITES IN WASHINGTON TODAY AND
THE GUY IN THE OVAL OFFICE WAS
NOT.
ALL ALONG HE WAS JUST TRYING TO
MAKE AMERICA GREATER AND HE HAS.
ROMNEY, I HOPE, ENJOYS HIS BRIEF
MOMENT IN THE SUN WHILE HE IS
LAUDED BY THE VERY PEOPLE WHO
SPENT THE LAST 20 YEARS
ATTACKING HIM BECAUSE IN A FEW
WEEKS, THE PHONE WILL STOP
RINGING.
HE WILL BE LUCKY TO GET BOOKED
ON CHRIS CUOMO’S SHOW.
WE WON’T EVER FORGET.
UTAH SHOULD NEVER FORGET.
AND IF I HAVE TO MOVE THERE TO
RUN AGAINST HIM AND FOUR AND A
HALF YEARS I WILL.
I DO LIKE THAT PARK CITY SKIING
AND THE SUMMER HIKING.
AND THAT IS "THE ANGLE."
LINDSEY GRAHAM WILL JOIN US IN A
FEW MINUTES, AND ROMNEY’S
PETULANCE.
BUT FIRST, OLD MAN’S LITTLE LAST
NIGHT, AS NEWT GINGRICH CALLED
FOR HER TO BE CENSURED.
IN THE CONSTITUTIONAL SCHOLAR
WHO VOTED FOR HILLARY CLINTON IS